parlons d'europe avec la maison de
l'europe des yvelines sur sensations
avec le soutien financier de l'union
européenne
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans parlant
d'europe sur sensation en association
avec tv 78 et la maison de l'europe des
yvelines se sont en ce moment les
erasmus death mathis godfriaux godfrey y
est allé vous demander si vous
connaissiez les politiques européennes
de mobilité et le programme erasmus cus
bon j'ai entendu parler mais
ça permet
d'étudier à l'étranger pendant une année
ou plusieurs etc je sais que c'est un
programme d' échanges d'étudiants
c'est l'union européenne qui finance des
d accueil d'étudiants dans d'autres pays
pour favoriser justement là la
connaissance l'interconnaissance des
pays c'est une des rares choses qui a un
coût raisonnable je pense
et qui est utile alors ça sert à ça
permet cette mode étudiants de pouvoir
travailler à l'étranger de faire autre
chose dans de changer de culture voir
quelque chose de différent du coup c'est
plutôt pour les étudiants étrangers
enfin français ou étrangers qui veulent
partir dans d'autres pays européens
je sais que c'est pour les étudiants
pour effectivement faire des des études
de l'étranger un procès très anciens
c'est ça permet aux jeunes étudiants
d'avoir une expérience
de six mois je crois dans une autre
université que celle de leur pays c'est
pas les étudiants qui partent à
l'étranger alors c'est d'envoyer des
échanges d'étudiants on envoie des
étudiants en espagne ou qui pas qui du
coup peuvent partager la culture la
culture d'autres pays ça va permettre
justement d'avoir une sorte d'ouverture
européenne d'ouverture à l'autre est ce
que vous pensez justement que ce
programme erasmus ça pourrait renforcer
un sentiment de citoyenneté européenne
au sein de l'union oui bien sûr
attention écoutez une employons pas les
grands mots ça sert à rien je pense bien
sûr c'est un mélange 926 universel je
pense que normalement oui on est d'abord
citoyen de sa nation on n'a pas besoin
d'erasmus pour se sentir européen c'est
vraiment parle par les échanges pas par
les choses pratiques qu'on peut bien sûr
qu'on peut se séparent l'amitié par ci
par les liens qu'on peut développer le
sentiment européen
oui on a bien entendu les reportages
mariera fait éliminer m'a rejointe
bonjourbonjour sahara vous êtes
coordinatrice jeunesse à la maison de
l'europe les yvelines et responsable
europe direct direct saint germain en
laye tout à fait oui nous en nous allons
en parler davantage par rapport à ce
musée russe mais d'abord une réaction à
ce que vous en vous venez d'entendre
alors d'un rien de très surprenant par
rapport à ce qu'on entend habituellement
c'est à dire des gens qui connaissent le
programme erasmus mais qui encore pour
beaucoup pensent que c'est réservé aux
étudiants ah oui je vois pas ce que on a
bien entendu
une année où plusieurs tout à tour les
étudiants où on a ouvert que on voit que
les gens restent sur les étudiants oui
ce qui s'est vraiment que ça erasmus
plus non pas du tout alors bien
évidemment on connaît tous le programme
erasmus qui permet d'effectuer en
semestre en dehors de son université
d'origine et dans une université
partenaire ailleurs en europe donc des
jeunes qui vont faire un semestre de
master ou de licence à dublin à lisbonne
ou encore à madrid en revanche on
connaît moins des jeunes
qui n'ont pas de diplôme ou peu qu'ils
sont déscolarisés qui sont en
réinsertion
qui sont dans un nouveau parcours de
formation et qui vont faire partie du
volet erasmus plus formation
professionnelle évidemment on va essayer
d'en savoir plus sur les politiques
européens de mobilité avant de parler de
programme erasmus plus les raphaël je
voudrais que vous nous présentiez les
autres qui existent
alors il ya des programmes de
volontariat vial ofaj l'office franco
allemand pour la jeunesse
au sein du programme erasmus et le corps
européen de solidarité
qui permet de partir plus tôt sur des
missions plus longues et aussi de type
volontariat
donc c'est à dire parce que tout à
l'heure on a bien entendre de six mois
ou plus jusqu'à un an jusqu'à un an pour
le corps européen de solidarité et en
2022 devrait aussi voir le jour le
programme alma et je pense que tout à
l'heure alberto bevilacqua vous en
parlera mieux que moi et il ya donc les
programmes erasmus plus cela fait 10
millions de jeunes oui on en profite et
a depuis sa création a fait quelques
mots par rapport à sa création et son
évolution oui alors le cd 71 ans que les
ministres de l'éducation se sont réunis
en se disant tiens ce serait bien qu'on
fasse quelque chose pour que les
étudiants puissent échanger il a quand
même fallu seize ans de plus pour que
naisse le premier programme erasmus en
1987 dans lequel il y avait le programme
étudiants mais ce qu'on appelait aussi à
l'époque le programme leonardo pour les
jeunes des lycées professionnels
le programme comenius fin plein de
choses et aujourd'hui on arrive à 10
millions de personnes sur plus de trente
ans d'exercice sur le programme erasmus
plus qui est ouvert pas qu'aux étudiants
c'est vraiment énorme comme chiffres
chez vous propose à présenter d'écouter
les témoignages d'alberto et de stefan
ils vont partager avec nous leurs
expériences de mobilité pour vous
expliquer un bon parcours du coup j'ai
fait un bac +3 et pour continuer en
master je voulais vraiment réfléchi à ce
que je voulais donc du coup j'ai voulu
faire une année de césure clairement et
du coup je me suis un peu des bleus un
peu intéressée au développement
personnel à tous qui est comportements
humains etc et puis même j'avais un
projet c'était vraiment de partir à
l'étranger pour faire un stage et de bas
c'était pour améliorer en l'anglais donc
j'y passais par la maison de l'europe et
tout ça pour le programme erasmus et
finalement avec la situation de locaux
vides et cetera la destination a changé
donc je couds j'ai choisi l'espagne donc
malaga et un stage tout simplement pour
découvrir sur tout le monde du travail
comment comment ça se passe la vie
là-bas même au niveau de l'argent au
niveau de même moi comment je vais me
comporter parce que je vais tout seul et
c'est le principal c'était vraiment le
stage en entreprise donc j'ai intégré
une agence en tant que assistant de
communication marketing donc là vraiment
je gd en fait les étudiants erasmus à
leur trouver un logement un stage en
entreprise des cours de langue s'il le
souhaitait donc du coup c'était hyper
enrichissant et de par sa ba voila je
profitais quand même de la ville je me
retrouver tout seul je rencontrais
vraiment le rein de gens mais de partout
là pour le coup je peux aller dans le
monde entier j'ai des contacts partout
c'est vraiment une expérience de dingue
mais tu rencontres des gens de faire
exceptionnel vraiment c'était à revivre
en fait je conseille à tout le monde
surtout si bas par exemple tu sais pas
quoi faire dans ta vie que tu n'as
aucune idée de métier ou coq est ce
vraiment partir à l'étranger parce que
du coup battu à découvrir de nouveaux
horizons de nouvelles personnes tu vas
connaître même de nouveaux métiers
peut-être donc cela en fait que tu
commences à tanrich et a et abat te dire
ok c'est ça que je veux dans ma vie mais
partir à l'étranger tout seul pas
accompagné c'est là où tu te surpasser
étudié ok je capable de faire ça mais
voilà après ça se prépare mais même moi
je voulais pas partir comme ça sans rien
prendre six sacs à dos y aller non
c'était pas mon objectif moi je voulais
quand même dépendre de la france où
avoir quelqu un organisme qui
m'accompagnent donc voilà passer par un
organisme je pense que c'est mieux et
même ça vous rassure vous êtes voit tout
seul et non vraiment il faut pas hésiter
faut y aller et même vous allez
apprendre énormément sur vous et c'est
exceptionnel encore une fois salut tout
le monde je m'appelle alberto je suis
italien je vous racontais un petit peu
ce que j'ai fait lors de ma mobilité à
l'étranger dans le cadre de mes études
j'ai fait mes études à sciences po paris
dans le campus franco-allemand européen
de 1,6 et dans le cadre de ma troisième
année j'ai décidé de partir en allemagne
j'ai décidé de partir en allemagne parce
que je considérais que c'était important
d'apprendre davantage sur les relations
franco-allemandes et donc sur l'amitié
franco allemand
donc je suis parti à bessat ross là où
une petite ville en allemagne centrale
plus précisément dans accès
grâce à l'initiative de l'eau fage
l'office franco allemand pour la
jeunesse
et cette initiative s'appelle
volontariat franco allemand
donc j'ai pu partir
dans cette ville pour animer des
activités dans une école dans un lycée
de cette île est aussi organisé des
projets en lien avec
l'amitié franco-allemande la
construction européenne
la francophonie et c'était très
enrichissant parce que j'ai pu beaucoup
apprendre tout en apprenant aux autres
et aux élèves en particulier
et donc j'ai pu beaucoup à apprendre sur
l'allemagne sur son histoire pleine
bouleversement surtout à partir de la
chute du mur en 1989 et même avant la
réunification et donc c'est une
expérience que je conseille fortement
parce que c'est très enrichissant et ça
m'a permis donc de réfléchir sur ce que
je voulais faire après sur mes projets
de carrière et j'ai décidé de continuer
sur cette voie là sur la dans le domaine
de la construction européenne ce qui est
mon travail aujourd'hui et donc je
trouve que c'est quelque chose que tout
le monde devrait faire donc de partir
dans un autre pays que son pays de
naissance
parce que on gagne en autonomie en
compétences et aussi non tout ce qui est
compétences humaines surtout donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à partir et je vous dis à
bientôt
et justement alberto bevilacqua est avec
nous
que de chemin parcouru depuis cette
expérience il ya eu un stage à la maison
de l'europe des yvelines et maintenant
vous êtes chargé de mission europe
direct seine et marne
nous avons nous allons parler on nous
avons bien entendu dans votre reportage
on en parlait davantage mais après avant
tout raconter moi un peu un petit peu
votre parcours alberto oui alors pendant
les études il fallait que je fasse en
stage
pour pour avoir plus d'expérience
professionnelle et donc j'ai décidé de
de postuler à la maison d'europe des
yvelines parce que je pensais que
c'était cohérent avec mon parcours en
master l'affairé open et donc j'avais
envie de m'investir pour
pour contribuer à la mobilité européenne
oui je vois alberto qu'est ce que cette
expérience de mobilité vous a apporté
professionnellement j'ai bien entendu
plutôt sur la compétence humain qu'est
ce que ça veut dire qu'est ce que vous a
apporté cette mobilité bas la mobilité
ce que ce que ça apporte c'est que ça
permet de prendre du recul par rapport à
ce que sont nos habitudes notre manière
de penser
nos coutumes et voilà ça permet un peu
de ba de se dire pourquoi je fais ça
pourquoi je le fais pas comme ça et
voilà ça permet de réfléchir sur nos
comportements sur notre manière de
d'avoir des relations avec avec les gens
et ça ça permet de s'enrichir tout
semble plutôt la diversité culturelle
des gens de partout oui c'est ça
ça permet de s'adapter à à
attuli tout les gens qu'on rend tous les
gens qu'on rencontre et
et voilà c'est un enrichissement qui
voit là ça vaut le coup d'essayer quoi
mais je vois vous êtes d'origine
italienne vous pouvez vous vivez en
france actuellement et est ce que votre
mobilité à renforcer votre sentiment à
de stunt et européennes et vous vous
sentez quoi vraiment italiens français
revient et ben c'est une question simple
mais la réponse est assez complexe je
pense mais je peux dire que les trois
sont indissociables dans mon cas donc
italiens français européen et je dois
dire oui que ma mè mobilité m'a permis
de comprendre que j'étais les trois à la
fois et donc les trois se complètent je
dois dire parfois il rentre en conflit
mais mais je pense oui dit que la
mobilité m'a fait comprendre que que je
peux être les trois en même temps
surtout oui elle est ce que ce sont les
voyages les études
qui ont renforcé votre sentiment de
student et européens oui absolument et l
sens par exemple voyage bah je pense que
si je pense que le plus grand défi
c'était de partir en allemagne parce que
c'est quand même une un pays qui est
très différent par rapport à mon pays
d'origine et donc voilà c'est un défi
que j'ai voulu relever et et c'était une
expérience extraordinaire et j'ai pu
survivre en allemagne veut que ça veut
dire que que voilà c'est la mobilité
nous permet de de mieux se comprendre et
de comprendre le pays le pays d'envoi le
pays où où l'on est et
et donc et donc voilà c'est ça c'est de
pouvoir s'adapter dans tous les pays
d'europe je reviens vers vous mari
raphaël est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous avez constaté avec les gens qui
aiment reviendra smooth ou est-ce qu'il
se sentait européen avant de partir dans
un autre pays où est-ce qu leur voyage à
changer quelque chose 6,8 c'était quoi
alors on a eu tous les cas de figure des
jeunes qui avaient très peu entendu
parler d'europe avant cette mobilité
pour qui c'était quelque chose de très
abstrait
d'autres qui se sentait vraiment
concernés qui avaient déjà participé à
des projets qui avaient déjà voyagé tout
simplement mais en revanche ce qui est
sûr c'est que quand ils reviennent ils
ont je pense mieux compris je vais pas
dire qu'ils se sont tous super européen
mais en tout cas ils ont mieux compris
ce que c'était que la citoyenneté
européenne et pour certains d'entre eux
vraiment ça a réveillé quelque chose le
fait de comprendre qu'ils ont une voix
qu'ils ont une opinion qui compte que
eux peuvent changer les choses au niveau
européen pour beaucoup l'envié de
repartir en se rendant compte que c'est
pas si difficile en europe de bouger
d'être mobile donc oui effectivement on
a des retombées très positives
il y avait des craintes avant de partir
bien sûr vous avez constaté oui alors il
est l'heure de passer ce sujet c'est
plutôt des sur les différences
interculturelles
quand on a des jeunes qui partent en
irlande où en allemagne c'est mon dieu
on pourra jamais dîné à 17h chez nous
c'est l'heure du goûter ceux qui partent
en espagne a contrario c'est à mon dieu
non passer à table à 23 heures c'est pas
possible ils ont peur des réactions des
gens par rapport à leur culture on a des
gens
d'origine maghrébine ou d'autres
religions ou avec une couleur de peau
différente et qui ont peur de pas être
accepté dans leur pays d'accueil mais
voilà on travaille avec des gens
extrêmement tolérant et ça se passe
toujours bien et oui le programme
erasmus puce ne cesse d'évoluer je vous
propose de retrouver les députés laurent
sfar ans au parlement européen de
strasbourg
elle est interrogée par hugo casadamont
je reçois aujourd'hui laurent sfar en
eurodéputés membres du groupe renault
europe et de la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation bonjour bonjour alors
on va s'intéresser aujourd'hui à erasmus
plus le européen pour l'éducation la
formation la jeunesse et le sport dix
millions de personnes en ont bénéficié
depuis sa création en 1987 ce programme
a beaucoup évolué avec de nombreuses
difficultés on rentre depuis le début de
l'année 2000 21 dans une nouvelle
période pour ce pour ce programme qui
est au coeur de la construction
européenne actuellement un budget de
plus de 26 millions d'euros lui a été
alloué soit près du double par rapport à
l'ancienne période 1 qui date et qui
était 2014 2020 quelles sont les
priorités pour le programme erasmus plus
pour son avenir sur cette période alors
en effet ce programme a beaucoup évolué
et puis avec erasmus il ya un plus
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'il a intégré
plusieurs niveaux de politique de
mobilité qui ont été testées par le
passé et qui sont rentré de plain pied
dans ce nouveau programme comme vous
dites ce nouveau programme il a
pratiquement été doublé on est même à 28
milliards pour les 7 ans qui viennent
donc c'est un immense progrès parce que
ça veut dire à la fois bien sûr plus de
gens qui est plus de jeunes et plus de
public ils vont partir mais aussi des
publics très différents puisque l'image
qu'on peut avoir d'erasmus c'est le
programme pour les étudiants qui partent
à mobilité qui font des colloques et et
qui profitent de ces études d'aller
plonger pendant quelques mois or c'est
beaucoup plus que ça aujourd'hui puisque
ce programme va avait déjà intégré
d'autres publics mais là c'est
radicalement le cas puisque il ya une
ouverture aux scolaires qui évidente
maintenant à la fois les élèves des
primaires vont pouvoir partir à présent
c'était jusqu'au collège mais aussi
leurs enseignants à partir de la
maternelle ça veut dire que de la
mobilité à l'étranger en europe même sur
des courtes périodes intègre vraiment le
programme il ya aussi apport du
parlement européen une clause inclusion
ça veut dire la volonté d'ouvrir la
mobilité à des personnes qui sont plus
éloignées en fonction de leur condition
sociale de leur lieu de vie géographique
du fait qu'ils puissent être porteurs
d'un handicap et que la mobilité soit
plus compliqué pour eux donc ça c'est
des objectifs qui sont intégrés et puis
il ya aussi la dimension liée aux
apprentis c'est un de mes combats phare
de favoriser la mobilité pour les
apprentis parce qu'on sait que c'est un
fort vecteur d'emploi c'est aussi très
important pour les régions
transfrontalières donc c'est la
construction de l'europe qui se fait
humainement et c'est ça que cela porte
donc très points très importants plus de
jeunes profils différents et puis on a
la dimension aussi importante de
l'intégration delà
de l'objectif climat qui rendent un
erasmus puisque on a pu faire en sorte
qu'ils soient mieux pris en charge et où
enfin pris en charge plus tôt vous pensé
justement que le climat l'environnement
c'est quelque chose dont on parle
maintenant tous les jours on peut pas on
peut pas évoquer l'avenir le monde de
demain sans parler d'environnement
c'était quelque chose d'important à
intégrer dans un programme tel qui rase
mus dans lequel beaucoup de pays
européens
d'ailleurs tous les pays membres de
l'union européenne participe au
programme erasmus et de quelle manière
réellement on va voir des changements
dans le programme erasmus en intégrant
l'environnement alors en effet il y
avait une sorte de paradoxe que les
jeunes qui sont à la fois les plus
concernés par l'avenir de la planète et
qui aussi se sont manifestés très
largement au moment des élections
européennes avec
cette motivation du climat
que donc la principale politique
jeunesse de l'union européenne n'intègre
pas cette dimension aujourd'hui elle le
fait j'étais à l'origine d'un rapport
d'initiative pour insuffler quelques
idées à la commission européenne dans la
plupart ont été reprises ans que j'en
suis très contente et donc ces avancées
qui sont très concrètes elles portent
sur deux dimensions il ya à la fois bien
sûr les thématiques des mobilités qui va
être
privilégié c'est à dire qu'une mobilité
à des fins d'études environnementales
l'acquisition de nouvelles compétences
je parle par exemple de l'apprentissage
sur des métiers du bois du chauffage va
va être davantage reconnus et d'autre
part le programme va permettre de mieux
prendre en charge des mobilités les plus
écologiques puisque jusqu alors ils
pouvaient plus intéressant de prendre un
avion low cost qu'un train donc
aujourd'hui les bourses permettent de
de prendre en charge le différentiel de
prix alors justement est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer quelles sont les
évolutions à apporter aux politiques
européennes de mobilité pour accroître
cette fois ci un sentiment de
citoyenneté européenne vous parliez tout
à l'heure d'inclure une plus grande
majorité des jeunes est ce que par
exemple des jeunes qui vivent dans des
milieux défavorisés où ils ont tendance
à peut-être à vivre plus en autarcie à
rester on parle de cité à rester dans
leur cité à ne pas forcément en sortir
est-ce que c'est des gens allaient aller
chercher de quelle manière la question
de partir ailleurs en europe ou à
l'étranger ne se pose même pas parce que
que ce soit des jeunes qui vivent dans
certaines zones urbaines ou ou alors
dans des zones très rurales justement
c'est pas dans le logiciel ce logiciel
est plus évident quand on est urbain
quand on vend en université en grandes
écoles est aujourd'hui les grandes
écoles et les universités intègre
vraiment la mobilité dans leur cursus
alors que en effet une toute une frange
de jeunes et même la majorité n'est pas
touché donc il est important pour sa de
prévoir la mobilité courte dès le plus
jeune âge parce que on sait très bien
que quand on a goûté à la mobilité
jeunes on se dit ça ouvre des
perspectives on se dit ça c'est possible
pour moi ça peut motiver apprendre une
langue étrangère
il ya beaucoup de témoignages et moi je
l' ai vu notamment dans le cadre de
l'apprentissage donc dans des cfa le
fait de toucher l'apprentissage c'est
aussi touché des jeunes qui sont plus
éloignée jusqu'à présent de la mobilité
quand on parle des centres de formation
des métiers dits manuels et tout d'un
coup tous les témoignages qu'on
recueille c mais oui c'est une
opportunité je peux le faire on rend les
choses possibles et ça devient beaucoup
plus accessible très bien alors la
france c'est le pays qui envoie le plus
d'étudiants via le programme erasmus
plus est ce que c'est important pour la
france de rester leader dans ce type de
projet pour la construction européenne
est de rester toujours un moteur de
l'union oui parce que ça prouve d'une
part que la france demeure
les aujourd'hui mais a toujours été un
pays très pro-européens donc elle s'est
beaucoup investie dans cette
construction humaine de l'europe et
envoyer des jeunes
partout en europe et à l'étranger c'est
aussi porter l'influencent nationale l
influence de la france et du soft power
qui est bâti des rencontres on va porter
des savoirs on va porter notre culture
mais aussi on va ramener des choses donc
évidemment c'est c'est très important
dans une influence nationale de la
france partout en europe et à l'étranger
est ce que vous comprenez ceux qui sont
contre ce programme belge entend les
arguments c'est à dire que des pays qui
ont des problèmes démographiques
et qui savent qu'ils sont pas forcément
attractif pour leurs jeunes savent très
bien que si les laisse partir il ya des
chances qu'ils aient plus de difficultés
à rentrer donc je comprends tout à fait
cette offre un prêt maintenant l'enjeu
c'est de faire en sorte que ces pays qui
sont pour beaucoup d'anciens des anciens
pays de l'est puisse reconquérir une
économie puisse reconquérir une
excellence académique et que pour sa
erasmus soit alors à leur service mais
je peux comprendre les freins qui qui
qui existe aujourd'hui et quand on
entend que un pays comme la turquie fait
partie et des pays participants en plus
des pays membres de l'union européenne
qui participe à toutes les éditions du
programme certains qualifient la
candidature de la turquie pour intégrer
l'union européenne de blagues ça cette
candidature date de 1987 d'ailleurs
comment est ce que on peut expliquer aux
gens que l'union européenne et a des
relations très compliquées avec la
turquie et que malgré tout la turquie
puisse faire partie de ce genre de
programme il faut dire que la turquie
n'est pas le seul pays tiers a participé
à erasmus erasmus à une audience
internationale il ya beaucoup de pays
qui sont incluses dans ce programme sans
pour être autant des candidats à
l'entrée dans l'union européenne donc je
pense qu'il faut décorrélée les deux je
pense que le débat sur la turquie la
turquie est clos sur l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne pour
autant
dans le cadre d'une stratégie de
coopération
de diplomatie et de soft power je trouve
tout à fait important qu'on ait ses
relations et ses échanges avec des
jeunes de tous les pays et vous pensez
que les jeunes turcs 1 c'est plus de 700
milles départ depuis 17 ans
reviennent en turquie après être être
venus d'un peu partout en europe et
après avoir fait ce programme j'ai pas
de chiffres jeu franchement je ne sais
pas c'est il est évident que partout
même dans notre propre pays partir en
mobilité donne envie l'étranger donne
envie d'étrangers voilà donc après et
tant mieux tant mieux il faut circuler
après ce que les jeunes turcs se fixe
plus particulièrement dans les pays
qu'ils visitent je n'en suis pas sûr je
n'ai pas les éléments j'ai pas les deux
très bien merci beaucoup laurence parent
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes eurodéputé membre de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation vous est également membre du
groupe renault en europe et aussi on
peut rappeler que les erasmus days se
dérouleront les 14 15 et 16 octobre
prochains pour en savoir plus il ya un
site internet alain erasmus days et
beaucoup de beaucoup d'événements merci
beaucoup leur sang avant de se quitter
vous le savez une grande consultation
citoyenne est en cours jusqu'au premier
semestre 2022 vous êtes invités à vous
exprimer à imaginer l'europe de demain
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs l'adresse de
la plateforme numérique future rue point
europa.eu une plateforme qui a été mise
en place à l'occasion de la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe et puis
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en podcast audio et vidéo
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensations et tv 78 très bonne
soirée à toutes et à tous
c'était parlant d'europe sur sensations
plus d'infos sur maison europe 78